so NBC says out with the old in with the
new the Kate so the capes the story of a
good cop who's framed for the crimes of
a masked criminal and then he stopped to
be killed and dead only to be trained by
Keith David I'm not gonna lie when
Goliath saw like Jota you got a train
under him so then he learns the ways of
illusion and magic tricks and then dawns
the names Kate the shittiest superhero
name in history next to Robin seriously
when you hear the Cape who doesn't think
the Cape
now superhero shows are pretty hard to
pull off because they all get canceled
like all of them that are not on the CW
and any show Summer Glau soon gets nixed
too so I mean I'm just watching the show
going what's the point of this it's
going to get canceled in a couple months
anyway or weeks because I'm a superhero
show we want to see superhero stuff we
want to see badass free which means one
of two things they're gonna try to show
it and have crappy CGI his cave was
really CGI and a couple sanded mmm or
they're just gonna cut out an entire
badass fight just show the aftermath of
him questioning the criminals either way
not good and there is a reason yeah I'm
picking the show apart I'm sorry for
people who like it just I'm just saying
but there's a reason Batman's all life
on that your superhero persona and your
human persona should feel like two
different things it should be two
different vibes this not only helps in
your anonymity but it helps us feel like
you mean business when you put on a cape
but he's the same character with or
without the costume it just makes it
feel like it's made for TV and there was
a scene where he's questioning a
criminal in a public place without his
mask good job dude your face is only on
every newspaper and that is not smart
that is not becoming of the Cape and how
long did he actually train him and he's
mastered these illusions that take like
a lifetime to master or at least years
and you get the distinct feeling that he
is trained relentlessly day in day out
for about 12 and a half days maybe he's
just badass like that more badass even
than Bruce Wayne who trained for like
five years and he got a new superhero
voice afterwards on that it's like the
biggest fan of dark man saw Batman
Begins and was like it's okay but I'll
make it better and here we are with a
cake I mean I'm not gonna lie it would
be cool to see the character get
reunited with his family and whatnot but
I'm not about to sit through a show
that's probably good to get cancelled
and does make me feel like I've wasted
my time and I think it'll get canceled
for a couple of reasons one I have seen
vastly
period shows get cancelled and - it's in
the kiss of death timeslot it's like NBC
was like all right we cancelled one
superhero show now let's make another
one and put it in a time slot where we
cancel everything
Monday night 9:00 p.m. on NBC it's not a
good place to be is this the whole
negative times a negative equals a
positive things I'm not gonna lie I
don't think elementary school math I
don't think it applies here but I
personally seen shows start out crappy
and turn cool but that's the exception
not the rule it was an unintentional
rhyme so I would like to see it become
better it has potential to be better but
as I always say there is a world of
difference between potential and reality
summer Glaus hot though
and that's something but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more than click right here to see
more